another channel that I've been really
into recently is Brent Rivera in fact he
posted this awesome diss track on his
sister which this dude this is late oh
look how how old he is now 20 he's 21
years old
yeah and he's still making like middle
school to high school content yeah yeah
it's gotta like eat away your [ __ ]
soul I mean you've known as a part of
thematic wants to grow up you know maybe
I feel like he there's so much a part of
his life I don't think it uh I don't
know I don't I think it's hard for him
to get his head out of it alright let's
see him like dog out his sister which is
weird as hell damn you you got him you
[ __ ] got him the bangs my man I'm
about to roast my sister it's a bang
bang bang you know man that sentence
right there I'm just saying I think I
think this yes or no yeah that's a poor
enough title right there man if there
were words I would never use towards a
sibling of the opposite gender it would
be bang bang bang yeah I mean it's a
bang bang bang yeah yeah I'm but no no
what does that even mean in the context
of this song I'm gonna kill her
why are you eating whipped cream in a
dis video against your sister is so
weird
[Music]
a man is like ten years late to distress
he [ __ ] you got to it mad late
because so this is like the classic
first first rap song flow yeah that's
just weirdly specific why are you big
enough your book you know my boy Ben
who's like mad popular Instagram yeah
see you wanted to [ __ ] him yeah I know
you want to [ __ ] my best friend I know
you want to [ __ ] them
dick burn you just got dissed and you
want to [ __ ] my best friend an idiot
idiot my cool [ __ ] widely popular
best friend who's also hot I would know
cuz he's my best friend I only have four
friends no for you weirdo I hope for it
literally again my best friend yeah
earng loser ship SS backsies sailing out
soon oh they ship them down when I get
the broom
I hate this I hate this I hate the way
he's talking to his sister while you
talk to your sister like this [ __ ] is
wrong with you I'm still I'm still not
over the that the thing with the bent
would been yeah yeah that's a he's gonna
Shh he ships them but then he said it's
all over when I bring out the broom it's
like no but you just you just made that
happen yeah yeah the [ __ ] you talk about
you just set them up in the song just so
you can say that you would make it stop
that's weird don't put y'all in the same
room to kiss but you're not gonna kiss
yeah cuz I'm gonna be there with the
broom big bad older bro this is just
we're gonna keep watching it you're 21
yeah you're 21 yeah yeah handy land yeah
without drinking cheap liquor being
broke in the club yeah you should be you
know I'm saying at 21 you should be
experiencing $200 in your bank account
yeah figuring out how you're gonna get
this book ya know you should be out
somewhere drinking [ __ ] cheap wine
yeah cheap something yeah and and and
learning how does she we he's got money
dude yeah learning how to socialize it's
weird yet seriously he's like that's why
I'm doing this I'm dissing my sister's
so I can get a table at [ __ ] honk or
okay yeah alright got it yeah I'm
bringing Candyland yeah and we're gonna
hang out and play board games in the
club yeah what do they do at clubs again
I've never been to one yeah this is this
one I mean some this is some dark [ __ ]
dude this is just him trying to keep up
with who he was wait wait go back
well you want if the description says
this was just for fun
Lexi is literally the best sister so no
hate love you Lexi comment
he got dissed with a weird sibling
rivalry yeah I don't really like this at
all
it kind of gives me the creeps a little
bit I can't not look at this and think
it's [ __ ] normal yeah because it's
like even in it like in what like a diss
track is supposed to be like yo you got
a your hairline look like Albert
Einstein you know I put your toothbrush
in the toilet when you was seven yeah
and I pooped on it you know and that was
doodoo on that toothbrush and so
literally you could eat my [ __ ] you know
like it was me who thrush yeah it's
supposed to be mean and he's talking
about I don't want to [ __ ] my friend Ben
I know you want to [ __ ] him and last
thing I know you want to [ __ ] my best
friend burn my hot best friend Ben well
you want to [ __ ] suck honestly I
don't blame you
you